Shayne Larry an Irish champion on Irish
soil in Britain's Open Golf Championship
the prospect might have tickled some
they found something funny on his phone
the only thing standing in Shane
Lowery's way was the weather and maybe a
few nerves in front of all these home
fans and on the first where Rory
McIlroy's opened dream died an early
death Lowry started with bogey three
years ago he blew a four shot lead in
the last day of the US Open but
back-to-back birdies suggested there
would be no repeat of that Tommy
Fleetwood remained his closest
challenger but it's been 27 years since
an Englishman won the Open the Westwood
so close so often but still waiting for
his first major was too far back but
stayed in touch play had begun two hours
early to avoid the worst of the bad
weather but even before the leaders were
halfway round the course the rain came
tumbling at his solving skies it was
possible to get even more of a drenching
but only a little
many local fans would have hoped to be
cheering rory mcilroy at this stage but
irish golf doesn't have a border and
nothing has the capacity to unite this
island more than a sporting hero it's
been a long time coming but being here
and speaking to people I think it really
goes beyond what we thought was possible
and it's just amazing and Ireland
there's your champion
chay-ara becomes the fourth Irishman to
win the Open Championship in 12 years
exactly how much state can you fit into
that claret jug in Woods Sky News royal
Portrush
[Applause]